hello and welcome to this video playing
Greg releases new propellant so on what
kind of society do we get time on oh um
yeah haven't yet started this hip and
trying to do something offbeat with f4
first 83 to prevent we should be formed
um I don't know this is any good I am
was something that I've thought of
during a recent bits game where this
idea could be good and I just just try
it out Kunta f3m tell ya so I go here
and cast a long potentially okay so what
about g4 he might take and play a five
year so maybe I have to prepare it a
little bit okay so he's getting trying
to get ahead with his Queen side play as
well however he has to be I mean he has
no square for the knight on f6 it's a
something he has to be aware of for
example be 40 x night before wouldn't
work due to g5 i think i think at least
if I go h4 what is he doing at age five
yeah but I can take her that that cannot
be so bad what is this where's is king
going here ever so g5 is he having
something that's played that must be
correct him it must be correct so there
are some interesting idea cm night f5 is
a funny move it takes 95 that could be
interesting but probably attacked too
much so let's think about it I can go g6
hear it let's do this song it just takes
it wow wow
Wow okay so why is that how is that
going to be I can go if five pawn takes
Knight 65 the 96 at the end but I'm not
sure that it does win it's also f5 has a
potential move the file you can go nitey
500k that that dead won't work just the
night on h5 is that so it's just very
unstable what about Bishop takes be fine
Bishop takes be five
I think this is quite interesting 94 I
can take this Evan so that won't work if
you take it upon I take on be fire this
this must be excellent yeah at the end
taking d6 here so Bishop takes is
probably what he wants to do Bishop
takes Bishop takes takes on b5 take on
b5 and they have this hanging there I'm
sorry I has to do this pink light before
i take the servants of and now Bishop g7
is also a mafia here if he recaptures a
plane I'd be five then take not sure
it's also look aged one I have okay no
no no difference okay okay let's do this
first king of seven maybe no no anyway
so see similar saying with the check
it looks like black should fall apart
here let's see you I can just take these
six on cata i think we probably win some
more material where is he going to be
eight year okay so going to plop take
this and no king to d8 I wonder if I
have egg something better actually than
98 but not see a this is good right it
doesn't have a couch I'll check or
anything and they have stuff like 23
here or so attacking this or what is
what is good here c3 4.66 their queen f6
I'm sorry time morning probably play be
5 i'm gonna have the check or group g1 i
don't know what's better
hmm right you're five actually takes c6
so 185 can i play five and hear ya that
should try and now Luke g1 someone still
have still is still going on here hmm I
don't see a maid here I don't see a mate
hmm any way to end the game here by mate
I don't see it am i threatening anything
you have five maybe ah I didn't see it I
just didn't see that my route game hang
was hanging oh my god that's crazy
that's absolutely crazy John for the
second rope yes give him another look
hey come on Chuck that's crazy what I'm
doing here and here are so many pieces
now that you can stop the pawns oh man
that it was such a complete win this
game white resides oh yeah I don't every
don't know what to say them yeah anyway
anyway so let's see where where were the
mates and everything yeah here I really
can barely move ha but I didn't find a
mate f5r only yeah five male here thinks
you things are not that clear ready they
are not here I mean ok I just crazy I
didn't say
they didn't see that my report subject
which is of course completely weird John
yeah I know normally you should just win
this I mean this black side I was so bad
that that you should never really
escaped inmate I think initially that
wasn't all that terrible like here okay
i can let details be five kills him as
well this is not bad i mean this this 95
95 was even stronger it it's enough it's
really enough clock one waiting to gain
is enough it just took me took me a tad
too long relief from ef5 is a lot
stronger f5 is a lot stronger because of
the director takia just probably it
cannot take as soon as I just take here
Warwick g1 the engines move k he's
totally tied down here is the problem we
have a similar this is a bit similar to
the game at here I'm actually with f5
opening up the position things like that
yeah that's a that's a lot stronger
material wise I'm okay anyway I've got
looking for points here against against
the three pieces and some damn you see
then this was the problem yeah sometimes
have this problem in doors in this open
Sicilians because I tend to find good
moves initially but it takes me so much
time then I'm at the end doing doing
something
tada stupid like here giving away
everything out of a completely winning
situation it just takes me long long
time because I'm not so used to the
position so i think i'm an experienced a
44 a player he wouldn't wouldn't think
like a minute and 20 seconds for
probably i mean this this also looks
strong claw yeah that's also the total
total destruction which is not really
surprising because how bad is this black
setup right so it should be something I
mean my solution was was kind of okay it
was just was just too slow okay thanks
for watching